hey friends i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i'm going to watch
the second
night city wire uh cyberpunk 2077 stream
um i wasn't able to watch it live
because i was working
life happened so i thought that i would
watch it now for anyone who doesn't know
i have played
a full four hours of cyberpunk already
and
i also have sort of kind of uh
got a little bit of insight into some
things with this game that i can share
while watching through this so if
there's anything that i see that i can
add more comment on
that you might not just know from
watching it um i will do that
i will pause and do that but we'll see
for now just reactions let's go
already into it it's already great and
welcome
hello holly you of knight city wire this
is the show from us
at city project red where we talk about
all things
cyberpunk 2077. in today's episode we're
going to be deep diving into lifepass
and showing you a brand new gameplay
video
as well as having a chat to philip from
our quest team
i'm going no matter going behind the
scenes and taking a look at how i refuse
to bringing the band
samurai to life and then we're showing
you another
new gameplay video and having a chat at
pavel
our senior gameplay designer about just
some of the tools of destruction that'll
be at your disposal in night city
cool let's get started street kid nomad
or corpo
which will you pick first again
definitely no matt i played street kid
when i played for the record
for my demo
i played this bit exactly yeah grew up
in haywood
the whole street was my family the cops
like
sometimes kind of like you if you're a
street kid because
uh why some of them are concerned like
maybe you came from the same
neighborhood they have more loyalty live
here die here
he that guy uh they have more loyalty to
like where you came from
you find some stronger tubers
this song is stuck do you want to spend
the rest of your days blasting scabs
okay i did all this in my playthrough
overnight
we have arrived the major
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
there was a drink there that was named
after
a bunch of like the legendary racing my
bobber for the first time through this
cyberpunks i guess oh and uh
first kiss in the middle of a synth
cornfield
we nomads choose who to make our family
a choice forges strong bonds and a
higher duty that stands solid as an old
oak
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
miss this you know camaraderie
i know it looks really pretty i didn't
get to go out to any of these areas
but i'm into it what i always liked
about nomads being that
i'm not from night city my character
isn't either it's like we're learning at
the same time when i like that
corpse got their rugby claws and
everything
all right yeah corporal is interesting
too i mean they're all very cool about
those reports
you asked for they were supposed to be
ready yesterday
the world's going to tear us apart when
the world gets around i have been inside
that
the world's never going to find out that
apartment in my street kid playthrough i
believe
you're going down with me no i'm not
[ __ ] joking
this isn't a request fee but no way
you're [ __ ] right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] if you work in our soccer counter
intel
you're always [ __ ]
today another killer song
tomorrow i'll get somebody else to zero
you
i can't wait for the soundtrack it's
going to be so good
that's arisaka like i said they're the
ones who pay the police in a lot of
cases
but you're not on top it's a borrower
everybody's corrupted keeps him there
work for yourself
live for yourself yeah you can get in
the flying cars
i don't think you can drive them but you
will be in them um
if you choose corporal i didn't get to
do that but i had a friend who played
corporal who did
um i was so curious if you'd even be
able to so it was neat to find out that
you can
philip it is so good to see you again
it's actually been a while since i've
had a chance to interview you about
cyberpunk
so i think for today we'll start with a
question that everybody wants to know
how does the path you pick affect your
time in night city
it actually affects your time quite a
lot throughout the whole game but let's
start at the beginning because basically
our game
has three different starts depending on
your life path uh as an example
yeah it's like the past three hours i
believe you have most of your time
in night city you know the streets you
know the gangs
you know the slang you kind of know
what's going on in the let's say lower
life
aspects of the city which can of course
give you lots of
good opportunities also later on in the
game but if you start as a nomad you
actually
used to be part of a nomad clan and a
nomad family
because nomads that roam the deserts
around night city
that we call the badlands actually value
their family above anything
but for what i relate to that also
actually left that family behind
and now the beginning of the game for
you will actually be
how to get into night city and house the
thing i can mention
um the street kid path they haven't
touched on this in
anything and that basically uh v has
just been to atlanta
i've seen no reference to that in any of
their gameplay i don't know what it's
going to mean boardroom
because you rose the corporate letter of
the arasaka do you want to see that
um basically gives you the ability but
yeah v went to atlanta and then came
back to night city and i don't know how
that plays into anything but it
was brought out more than once which of
course can give you many nice
opportunities later on
so this isn't just about the stuff good
chair can you maybe
help people understand how this
translates into the gameplay
yeah so the thing is we make cyberpunk a
real
rpg and part of that is i keep saying
that it's not pg not an fps this is an
rpg start
to the end and of course you know people
are like
effectively treating it like it's an fps
for some reason like this isn't
he's a nerdy as hell very in-depth rpg
gonna be a lot of dialogue
not that much and as an example we do
that by giving you additional options in
dialogues
so i can give you one specific example
and this is a mission where you have to
steal a flathead robot
from the maelstrom gang basically these
maelstromers
stole that flathead before from a
corporate transport
and the owner of that corporate
transport merit the stout
and even within that objective we want
to give you some options which as an
example i mentioned a corporate life
path
you basically know what meredith style
is really about you can read between the
lines
and you can get some additional options
that maybe actually later
enable you to do a completely different
thing with the maelstrom gang
and if you're a nomad you know exactly
some more details about how these
maelstroms
would have even been able to steal a
robot like that from meredith stout
who's part of the very powerful militech
corps
i played a street kid as a street kid we
as an example don't give you a specific
new dialogue option in that dialogue as
a street kid
you do not have a lot of experience
dealing with higher up people like
meredith stout
but we want to give you additional
options that fit your life path very
well
so later when you actually talk to the
maelstrom gang one member of the gang
offers you
some illegal substance but as a street
kid
you actually know what this is about you
can talk some shop with him
i didn't do that actually make that
character like you a little bit more
yeah i got out of that do you have a
commission
without fighting them on the video the
mouse gang at the first
is about nomads so the nomad like i made
the corpos and the maelstrom gang fight
each other
is this somewhere you get to visit even
if you don't pick nomad to start with
yes absolutely so the thing is night
city is surrounded by this huge
landscape
that we call the battle i really didn't
expect that there you go cool you can go
there whenever you want so as an example
if you actually do play the nomad life
path at the start and you are in the
badlands
you can even see night city on the
horizon it is so loud
later in the game if you want you can
just take your car and drive out of the
city
you can go there whenever you want thing
is you might not want to
because the badlands can be a pretty
dangerous place at first
because time has not been very kind to
the badlands
there have been many wars in the past
there's global warming
so most people that do live out there
don't really have another choice about
it
or are nomads that love this life and
are all about it and are very
battle hardened we of course also want
to tell their stories
because we want to tell many many
different stories
throughout the cyberpunk genre which
means that you will also find missions
that lead you out in the badlands
or where you deal with the people living
there i did not know that that's cool
can you tell us a little bit more about
the character padre
he's the guy we see giving his business
card to street kid v
in the video yes who is this he was like
a mob boss yeah so padre is actually one
of the fixers in night city
and fixers are people that work as
intermediaries
so if someone who has a lot of money
needs a problem solved they go to a
fixer
and a fixer then finds people who can
solve that problem and these people are
i like him actually the cyberpunks
fixers are very tight
he also had a padres specifically
dialogue in haywood
options where you as a street when i was
in the car with him you already know him
you might have already seen another one
of our fixers well he like liked me more
or less based on what i did he works in
a different part of the city
so specifically padre you might know him
as a street kid
but even if you played other life paths
you might sooner or later meet him
because he's operating in haywood which
is a pretty big place with many good
jobs
so if you want to make some cash there
you will sooner or later deal with padre
you have to get in the car with padre as
the street kid right at the very start
now on my first playthrough pretty sure
i'm going to be picking nomad
but for those watching we would love to
know what you'll be picking so have a
think about it
and send us a tweet don't forget that
later in this episode
we're going to be showing you another
new gameplay video i couldn't afford the
katana
i really wanted it about just some of
the tools of destruction
that will be at your disposal in night
city for anyone who hasn't watched my
previous video about music
i did get plays a huge part in bringing
night city to life uh sniper rifle could
shoot through walls
about things like radio stations and
even the original score
but today we're going to take a look
behind the scenes how refused to
bringing johnny silverhands band
samurai to life
i wouldn't write these lyrics for myself
so it's kind of interesting i love the
quality in this game like the mindset of
who is this character and what would
they write about what
what's their agenda you have to write
technically for
you kiana reaps to try to like catch a
language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
part of this game
[Applause]
it's a cool idea having a full band
recreate an in-game band don't make it a
game man that's cool it's neat
is a reason why we're here
[Music]
this is really high production oh didn't
mean to pause it
my bad he knew refused and he knew my
voice and he said oh that's a perfect
voice for
for johnny
[Music]
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when john is supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy got a
dragon bit of a punk yeah
make him kneel down with gas then light
them up so of course there are things
that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this squibble
that's fighting against like the
the corporals and that's definitely
something that's been a part of my life
and a part of the few stuff we came out
of the punk rock scene of
northern sweden he's like the future
version of us
it's cool i'm into it so i i think it
makes sense i think it totally makes
sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him you know so it's pretty cool
it's a neat neat collaboration
but yeah but like white vibrato
[Music]
and then let me just sort of feel i mean
yeah slowly
we don't have a different mode than just
going all
in so we really work on these songs
trying to make them as good as possible
then they're not actually our songs it's
interesting as
as a musician to play another musician
because that's essentially what we're
doing i mean we're not here as refused
we're here yeah this is going to be
really common i'm sure another game has
done this at some point
it's still around you know i forget
things a lot though this is
[Music]
that's the most swedish thing i've ever
seen in my life
[Music]
[Music]
i've been doing this for a very long
time but then
when someone comes in and says i'm happy
with everything
except for as a limb again it's as a
as uh
okay the shouting is great but think of
that accent so think of that like
enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very difficult she has to be english too
screaming like that and it's hard to
sort of keep swallowing some
syllables there adjust your accent
that's super interesting
so it's been a bit kind of frustrating
it wasn't it wasn't so he has to sing as
someone else and in a different accent
horrible but it wasn't
great but i mean i get it i mean we have
to maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is me
like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know you you think the things like the
rhythm and you think i didn't expect to
find this
like i didn't expect this to be in here
and i didn't expect to find it so
interesting
like learning a bunch of [ __ ] that i
didn't expect right now yeah
neat painful
[Laughter]
i've had that when i've done voice
acting before they told me to change a
certain word because it doesn't sound
right in my accent and they wrote it for
an american but they don't want me to
sound australian
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of as
as a person that's not a gamer i don't
think i fully understand the impact that
this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
like then that's gonna be great i mean
we we are spending a lot of times
trying to get this right trying to get
it to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting
i feel like yeah as someone who's not a
gamer this must be weird as hell of
making music actually
you can already find three samurai
tracks available on streaming services
chipping in never fade away and the
ballad of buck ravers
but we're excited to announce a new song
called a like supreme which is coming to
streaming services
today that means you can check it out
once the show is over
cool don't forget that if you're tuning
in late or if you just want to watch
anything again we will be uploading
everything to our channel soon
next up pavel and i are going to
introduce you to some
creative ways that you can solve
problems in night city
discombine weapons i'm i'm interested to
see more than this because
more about this because i didn't expect
the
like i said sniper rifle that shoots
through walls so i don't know the limits
of this stuff like they could get real
crazy
ugh whole game's rendered in real time
too
i have a job for you a client of mine is
making an
arms deal he needs protection
but um crafting was uh disabled for the
demo so i still don't know how it works
which is a bummer
pierce is concrete i guess cool
oh i like that i think that that's the
shotgun that i used actually
it felt like i was shooting a taser
that looks good
smart weapons oh you get like perfect
dark type stuff here
oh yeah okay cool we've seen that i
think in one of the gameplay demos
nice i wish i could have tried one of my
melee weapons
i didn't even try the hand-to-hand
combat i have no idea how it feels aside
from takedowns i did do a bunch of
takedowns
mantis plays i did see them in a stall
cool
get that put in your arm i wonder how
that works gameplay-wise like for you to
swap between that stuff
are you willing i wonder if you can have
yeah rocket arms and mantis blades
i would like all of the above
pavel thank you so much for joining me
now there was an
awful lot in that video right because
it's more than just guns
absolutely we have many weapons we have
ranged weapons we have cyber where we
have
offensive cyber where defensive cyber
armor
we could talk for hours and hours about
this stuff
i think just for today's episode we
should keep it simple and let's just
talk about guns
can you tell us the different types of
guns that will be in the game
so we have three distinct types of guns
in our game we have
power weapons we have tech weapons and
we have smart weapons
now power weapons are the most similar
to contemporary
one thing they can do which normal
weapons cannot is ricochet bullets off
of surfaces
so you can hit somebody hiding behind
cover or high
on the wall so cool now tech weapons on
the other hand use electromagnetic power
to propel
a fully metal projectile to extreme
velocities
what that allows them to do is to punch
through cover
or punch through walls to hit somebody
who's not even
aware that you're there so i guess
that's the sniper rifle i have guided
missiles
i say sniper rifle actually track
targets in real time
so you can hit somebody who's dodging
running away from you
or you can hit somebody who's hiding
behind cover
i feel like it's gonna be hard to choose
doesn't just contain i always have a
favorite weapon in virtually every game
rpg so can you tell us how you guys
approached introducing those rpg
elements into gunplay
so i can tell you one thing holly it
wasn't easy to merge those two elements
together
now we've spent a considerable amount of
time
merging the rpg and fpp side of our game
what the player will experience is that
v
changes from a small time mercenary to a
legend in the world of night city v
becomes
more and more proficient in using
weapons as the game progresses
reload times become shorter the accuracy
of your weapons grows you will
have faster you can aim better too yeah
move faster with your weapons
everything becomes if you just start
using a weapon
you might not necessarily better aim
with it as well as you will once you
use it more designed for you you're
supposed to feel like a newbie to a
weapon you've not used
questions for you pavel if you're
feeling up to it of course
okay well the first is going to be how
do you find more weapons in night city
like where will players be looking
i find i found the sniper rifle by doing
a side quest players to look
everywhere for new and exciting weapons
where i took down what's called a cyber
psycho
adventures and they will house a random
minibus of weaponry that you can get
however
the best weapons not random behind will
be part of the story enemies or
loot caches that we have everywhere in
nice city the weapons rarities range
from
common to uncommon up to rare and then
legendary
and people make a walkthrough for this
they can't
legendary weapons are very specific in
such a way that they
possess unique abilities that you will
find on
no other weapons in the game the players
will actually
need to make some tough choices to find
some legendary weapons because
maybe they need to choose whether to
kill a person
who holds the legendary weapons that
they want or to spare them
because they like them as a character so
next question let's talk about
weapon modifications what mods can
people give to their weapons in
lightsabers i don't know anything about
this
two types of modifications in the game
one of them would be
modifications that we call attachments
so these would be scopes
and silencers and you can see them
actually being
attached to your weapon as you're
playing the game they give you
statistics advantage and they give you
more opportunities in gameplay
the other part of mods would be software
modes
now these are basically small chips that
you install in the
in your weapon and they actually change
the statistics of the gun
they can give you damage they can give
you accuracy or they can give you
more fire rate some of those mods
actually change the
gun play on a more fundamental level so
they can give you non-lethal rounds or
biochemical rounds to play through that
armor
even faster my favorite thing about this
game so far is that final
question for everything you know about
it i still feel like i don't know [ __ ]
like i just don't know what
what's gonna happen so far in knight
city oh there are so many weapons that
it's hard to choose
just one but i can mention some
manufacturers with their weapons that i
absolutely adore
the first manufacturer would be tsunami
defense systems
who produces the sniper rifle nekomata
that's a tech sniper rifle that means
that it can pierce through walls it
might have been
actually hit somebody who's hiding
behind cover
or who doesn't even know you're there of
course i also like a close quarters
approach
and what that needs is a shotgun one of
the shotguns that we have in the game is
budget arms carnage now that thing is
cast from
pure steel and you like that they all
have cool names however you can
cut a person clean in half with it
another shotgun that i absolutely love
it's for a more refined approach i would
say
is a smart shotgun that
thing has eight barrels jesus and that
means jesus christ
eight targets independently now killing
an
entire room was never simpler
you look so ridiculous thank you for
having me uh i'm actually pretty
interested to see what kind of weapons
people discover when they uh play
cyberpunk for themselves
yeah it should be fun actually genuinely
two this is a reminder that those who
wish to dive deeper into the law
can now pick up the world of cyberpunk i
should probably do that
i should probably get a brand new book
created in collaboration with
dark horse books that will give you an
extensive look
at what makes night city tick before
jumping into the game
this november that is it for today's
episode thank you so much for joining us
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again we will be uploading everything to
our channels shortly
thank you so much for tuning in and
we'll be back with
night city wire episode three soon
just soon huh all right
well i guess that's that oh sorry there
you go just november 19th again
super into it uh i remain very excited
about the game
stop advertising me because for this
game it is going to work you have to
stop
it's not fair um there's still like some
time left though so i'm curious about
what the rest of this time is you're
seeing it
why is the time left
it's nothing okay
no okay um that's just because i
captured it that's what i'm watching
uh yeah i feel like there's not a ton of
that that i actually can touch on it
looks dumb but this is really just my
very genuine reaction sorry if i spoke
too much or too little uh
people are very picky about reaction
videos i don't know
um for anything that i have touched on
that i can speak about again
as always let me know if you have any
questions about cyberpunk uh i will do
my best to answer
anything that i can and that's it for me
today everyone i'll see you guys next
time
bye